thanks to audible for keeping legal
eagle in the air
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are going to have
a somewhat unusual video of some of my
favorite youtubers who are here at
VidCon so I thought it would take the
opportunity to corral some of these
great youtubers to spend some time and
talk about some of the legal issues that
they deal with on an everyday basis
being creators on YouTube and I am
thrilled that we have the creator of one
of my favorite music related channels
this is Corey Arnold from twelve-tone
Corey thank you so much for joining us
on the yet to be tiny
legal eagle interview show yeah thanks
for having me like devin said my name is
corey i run a channel called twelve-tone
I'm a music theorist and I do a bunch of
different types of musical analysis one
of our main series is we'll look at like
pop and rock songs and the harmony and
the compositional aspects of those which
I think pretty clearly falls under like
commentary and critique in terms of fair
use but I still obviously I get a lot of
fraudulent copyright claims and I was
wondering like I know that the actual
copyright claim system inside YouTube is
not an actual legal entity but once it
gets to like DMCA takedown notices and
stuff I'm wondering sort of what the
disincentives are for companies to hook
major labels and whatever to issue those
sorts of fraudulent claims because I
mean I hope there are some yeah well
it's a great question because obviously
copyright is a huge issue on YouTube
these days both some of the people who
are pirating things illegally and you
know creators who are doing things that
are perfectly within their legal rights
and yet they are still being claimed by
some of the rights holders we've seen a
lot of traffic coming from some of the
major music studios I'm sure you and I
could probably name some that are
particularly known for making false
claims against creators and so an answer
to your question yeah yes there are
actual penalties for companies and
individuals that make false claims and
there there are a couple of things most
of them stem from what's called the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act or the
DMCA and as you alluded to one of the
mechanisms that
holder has to take down what they
consider to be illegal material is a
DMCA takedown and that is basically the
company saying to a platform or a
website you are hosting material that is
illegal and you should take it down I'm
giving you notice of it and really if
the platform or website wants to avoid
being liable for copyright infringement
they have to take it down and that's
something that a lot of creators don't
understand is that YouTube sometimes
doesn't have discretion to take it down
but that being said there are ways of
making sure that when companies do take
creators videos down there are some
penalties to them the first is that when
you issue a DMCA takedown that's a real
legal document that that is not the
YouTube Content ID system this is
something that's enshrined in law and
the most important thing is that if you
issue a DMCA takedown in bad faith and
it ultimately goes to court you can be
liable for attorneys fees and so there's
a bit of a fee-shifting provision in the
DMCA that if you don't issue a takedown
a good-faith you might be on the hook
for not only your own attorneys fees but
the attorney's fees of the plaintiff
companies even the studios and labels
are very reluctant to issue DMCA
takedowns because they can be on the
hook for copyright misrepresentation and
they can be on the hook for the
attorneys fees if the Creator Sue's them
under Section 512 F which is the
misrepresentation part of that statute
unfortunately creators are not likely to
sue the the rights holders for making
these false claims you know I'd love to
hear from your perspective what has
happened to the extent that you have
have to had to deal with with some of
these takedowns yeah so I've gotten a
fair amount of copyright claims all from
one label who I probably shouldn't name
I don't know but mainly just a lot of
videos that have done whenever I've done
their songs the one thing one time what
has gone a little bit further I actually
got one actual takedown notice from the
label not the the major label that was
making the claim it was the rights
holders for the individual the band they
issue to take
yeah and then I took it to the next
level on the YouTube appeals process
which says effectively either back off
or actually sue me like take me to court
right and they weren't gonna do that but
once once I filed that pretty quickly I
get this email from the lawyers of that
band saying hi we are this band's lawyer
and we got this notification we would
like to investigate further but we can't
watch the video because it's not on
YouTube and no one in this office has
seen it so could you send us a copy so
we can figure out if this is copyright
infringement I was just like no I can't
do that I don't I didn't have it in the
first place it was an old video but it's
just like in that case that's if your
client didn't check with your their
lawyers that feels like a pretty obvious
admission of negligence yeah that's
that's pretty crazy and it's not at all
surprising frankly because often the the
people that issue the the first Content
ID claims are not connected to the legal
departments of these same companies and
sometimes the training isn't very good
and it will be a non lawyer that issues
one of these DMCA takedowns and after
the DMCA takedown is issued the video
goes down and the lawyers can't view it
you can't view it which is hysterical
that you had to deal with the lawyers
even asking to take a look at your your
video and there's a famous Ninth Circuit
case called Lenz versus um G people may
be familiar with um G I've heard the
name yes yes and it involves a case
where they issued a DMCA takedown
without even really considering whether
fair use applied and the Ninth Circuit
said the DMCA requires you to form a
good faith belief before you issue the
takedown and not forming a belief is not
the same as a good faith belief and so
they got severely reprimanded for
issuing this takedown without really
considering fair use and so now it is
really the law of the land at least in
California and the rest of the Ninth
Circuit that you have to at least
consider whether the video is fair use
or not or you could be liable for
misrepresentation
and in libel for attorneys fees for the
improper take down and that's
interesting it's like in cases where you
don't like just get an email from their
lawyer saying we didn't look at this
like how do you as a I my understanding
and I might be wrong here but my
understanding is that in terms of fair
use nothing actually is or isn't fair
use technically until a judge rules on
it so what is the process of sort of
proving that you did or didn't have a
good faith belief that it wasn't fair
use yeah I think those are two separate
things I've heard people say you know
nothing can be certain unless it's
litigated and that's technically true
but that's definitely true about
anything not just copyright you're never
certain until a judge has you know
stamped the the judgment but the
underlying issue of how would you prove
that well in an ideal world you would
file suit and then you would be entitled
to discovery which you know we we tend
to focus on the drama of the trials on
TV and in movies but the vast majority
of what lawyers do day in and day out is
actually just the the process of getting
all the facts that are relevant in the
u.s. at least we've sort of done away
with trial by surprise we want everyone
to know all of the facts before they get
to trial and so a lot of my job has been
spent writing discovery requests where I
will ask for the relevant documents from
you and in court you are obligated to
turn those over and I will often conduct
these interviews of the witnesses of the
other side those are called depositions
and so if state of mind is relevant then
you would be entitled to sue them and
then find out all the people who made
the decision and and you'd be able to
put them in a chair and you would ask
them under oath what they thought about
this particular song that was taken down
or this is a video and you would be
entitled to all the documents maybe all
the email traffic where they dealt with
this particular video and and it's a
cumbersome process but that's how you
deal with it you you get the discovery
in that topic I really hope that
creators are less afraid of copyright
issues and the nature
I think that there's there's a lot of
great stuff out there and there's a lot
of bullying going on certainly a lot of
copyright infringement on the Internet
as well but for you know all of these
music channels that I see you have your
channel paul davids Adam Neely you guys
are doing such great work with music
education and we all have music business
education yeah look we've taken these
classes like I knew anyone who has a
music degree knows at least the
rudiments of copyright law yeah cuz we
have to right right so we know what
we're doing for the most part that's
awesome well I hope you keep at it
I love the channel I recommend anyone
interested in music theory twelve-tone
the the channel that Corey created
really is the absolute pinnacle of
musical analysis on YouTube so keep at
it and hopefully the the studios don't
give you too hard of a time with your
with your material I'll just keep
appealing yeah sounds good well Corey
thank you for joining the untitled
legally interview yeah thanks for having
me okay cut the cameras thanks for doing
this interview Corey I really appreciate
he know Corey have you ever heard of
audible you might really enjoy this
audiobook how music works by David Byrne
he's the lead singer than Talking Heads
and he does a really fantastic job of
explaining how music has evolved over
time according to both the context that
it's written in and how music technology
advances wait what yeah I know you're
already an expert about music theory but
you know it's an amazing exploration
about music from one of the great pop
authors living today it talks about how
one genre absorbs the influences of
other genres how musicians anticipate
what their audience will want and how
instruments were suited for music venues
not the other way around no I don't care
if you've already read the book why
don't you just listen to it again on an
audible audible is giving legal eagles a
free 30-day trial with two free
originals all you need to do is go over
to audible.com slash legal eagle or text
legal eagle 2 500 500 you can download
any audiobook if you're choosing and get
two free audible originals no no no they
should use my link not yours
no I don't
you also have a link people should use
my link because clicking on the link in
the description really helps out this
channel kori you should definitely go
and check out how music works on audible
just head over to audible.com slash
legal eagle or text legal eagle - 500
500 or click the link in the description
yes I'm talking to you Corey who else
would I be talking to